I don't understand how we're getting so
off topic this is about feminism
feminism today whereas everybody wants
to make this about their individual oh I
hear all the the multitude of other
things that factor into my person great
this is about feminism it's about
Womanhood I understand that all of you
have your own individual experiences and
the other things that feed into you as a
person that's perfectly fine but this is
where intersectionality falls off the
planet and loses I would argue probably
the vast majority of people including me
I'm not even a feminist I don't give a
crap about feminist arguing amongst
themselves about who's the most
victimized but this is annoying to
listen to I honestly just I don't
understand anything anybody's even
trying to get at